hey everybody its Jessie welcome to live
coding with Jessie I'm sorry about the
delay
I thought that was a long delay
yeah so like a half-hour ago maybe I
decided to download some updates
I wanted to restart my computer anyway
because if you remember yesterday the
camera wasn't working and usually if I
restart it works well you know for weeks
so unfortunately the updates took longer
than I thought
so that's why I started late I was
trying to get a stream going on my
laptop but I couldn't get it working
fast enough before the updates finished
so now it's everything's working now so
again sorry about that lets it's saying
that the resolution is not good on this
stream so let me know how it's going
all right so today we're gonna start
sorry I just my computer just literally
came back on you know two minutes ago
oh trying to get everything everything
ready okay
so today we're gonna start for really
from from the basics so I had some
feedback saying that you know a lot of
you like the beginner type of stuff so
I'm not always gonna be doing beginner
level work but what I'll try to do more
of is even when I'm doing some of the
advanced work I'll try to explain the
steps you know a little bit better so
that you know someone who is a beginner
might be able to understand so today
we're gonna go back to project one so I
don't know how many of you were we're
watching for project one but we're gonna
go all the way back there and we will
update some of our packages and because
we need to make some changes to that so
I've already gone back into the repo and
I've opened some issues with some of
those changes and we'll talk more about
some of the changes I think I did a few
weeks ago on a stream we may do some of
the changes live on a stream we'll see
how it goes but I thought this might be
cool to do because I'm sure a lot of us
have projects that we've done before and
now you know six months later a lot of
the packages that we use might be out of
date well you know how do you go about
updating things so that you don't break
them so that's what I'm gonna try to do
today and I have not done anything with
this I haven't practiced at all so we'll
see it may not work at all we may break
it so we're just gonna kind of try to
update things and test and see if things
work we're going to be using
you'll get so we can certainly revert
back if we need to we could even do
things on another branch and then merge
when we're certain that everything works
so let's let's give it a shot so as I
said before since I'm trying to do this
you know for beginners I'm gonna start
you know right off the bat I haven't
liked any commands yet let me try to
find the right
it's this alert okay so let me get
switch you over to the screen there we
go and oh I also did put that yesterday
her should asked about that electron app
that we had started up but I had
forgotten to make the repo for that repo
is now available so that's in that that
marcom that fu s Markham organization
that all the other projects are in now
there's a project for that of electron
one Oh Blake asks if I'm in another
office no I just left the light on which
I don't want the light on so hold on a
second
there we go
when I was trying to do the stream from
my MacBook the camera on there was just
super dark so I had to turn the light on
but I can't stand the glare off the
screen when the lights are on all right
so let me make this bigger so you all
can see so I'm just starting here right
from my terminal okay I happen to be
using a program called I term - you can
find the link for that in the
description below this video but you
know you don't have to use this you
could use a different program you could
use you know the built in terminal and
like Visual Studio code or you know just
the normal terminal that comes with
whatever computer you're using so the
first thing we're gonna do is we're
gonna go into for me I keep all my stuff
in a projects folder so I just CD the
command a CD and then you type the name
of the folder and now I'm gonna check
this out and find our here we go see I
react is the name of our projects we
need to go into that folder so I'm gonna
CD again and go see I react once you
type in the first few letters you can
hit the tab key and it will assuming
that there's only one file but it could
be based on what you've typed in already
it'll just autocomplete the rest not a
big deal for short names like that but
when you get into some of these longer
names like like this one it's very
helpful because you know one little you
know mistake and the computer has no
idea what you're talking about so it it
won't try to guess what you meant
if you accidentally misspelled a word
you know in the middle here alright so
first thing that we always want to do
when we go into a project that's being
tracked you know it has a github
repository or any type of git
repositories we want to do a git pool
this will pull any changes oops since I
restarted my computer I have to put
passphrase so I'm going to grab that
quickly from LastPass and I will do that
on my other screen so that you all don't
see my my password
yeah all right I'm gonna put that in
there Oh No
so not it this should work let me try to
copy it again there we go and then I'm
gonna do SSH ad and that way I won't
have to put this passcode in again at
least until I restart my computer okay
so now we we should be able to do let's
do it get pull make sure just make sure
all right yeah I did run so we're
already up to date so we don't have
anything in our repository so we were
safe to begin working so now I want to
open this up I'm gonna open it up in
Visual Studio code I've been using that
a lot lately we did most of this project
using atom but it's fine to switch
between our code editors so the shortcut
for Visual Studio code if you have it
installed and you've installed the
command-line interface you just do code
and then dot you put the dot there it
opens up the whole folder there we are
and now I'm gonna make this take up the
full screen
and let's let's open up our terminal
here so our integrated terminal so now
we won't have to switch back and forth
we can type in our commands right here
and first things first let's check out
our package JSON this is what we're
going to be concerned with for for most
of the time so I'm going to get rid of
this sidebar and I'll make that a bit
bigger I hope that's big enough for
everyone to see and I'm gonna move this
down just a bit and I could always make
it bigger when we need it so let's just
let's check some things out here so
we're running next to point 4.3 and we
can see the latest version is four point
two point one so we're way behind
same way with react latest version of
react is sixteen point two so we have
some work to do here
let's see what else so I'm just going
through this just to refresh my memory
on what we're doing for this project so
we have Auto formatting going of our
code linting set up so it's good
it looks like most of what we're using
can be updated alright so I just checked
the live chat here harsh it says that
there are no braking changes so if we
run yarn upgrade latest it should work
so let's do that first of all let's
confirm that it is running locally right
I would hate to have it that something
right now that's going on be breaking it
and somehow think that what we're about
to do will break it so let's do let me
see what we had to come in for dev ok so
I'm gonna run it in this other terminal
so we'll go yarn dev and hit enter and
we'll see it's going to start we'll be
able to check this site out in just a
minute there we go we're on localhost
3000 I'm also gonna start up this end
rot server we got here believe I need to
do this and grog there we go I'm going
to paste a link and you should be able
here in the live chat you should be able
to see the site as we work on it with
that link and I forgot to start my timer
so I'm gonna do 25 minutes of like
coding updating testing and then after
that I'm gonna take a five-minute break
I'm gonna go back to the live chat
answer any questions that you have so if
you've asked a question already just
hold on till we're done with this twenty
five minute period I'll answer your
questions if you can't stick around for
the answer you could always watch the
recording of this video you know
sometime later on you know whenever
whenever you have time to watch it so it
looks like yeah we have people connect
that's working and I will pull over a
browser window as well onto this screen
and I will check it out the localhost
3000 - great it looks like it's working
use the home page is working let's click
on some things okay awesome
so since that's working now let's update
so let me check out again what Harshit
has suggested to run yarn upgrade latest
and was that - - yes it's so down here
I'll bring it up a bit so down here in
our terminal
we're gonna run yarn update upgrade and
then we'll do latest I apologize for the
yawn I haven't had very much caffeine
today I had like a cup of tea and it was
a really old tea bag it's been sitting
in my desk drawer for like two years so
wasn't the greatest cup of tea
alright so just to show you how much
that does this is this is what it's all
you know kind of installed and went
through all these packages so we have
our base packages that we can see in our
package JSON but they all have
dependencies of other packages so I mean
look at that quite a bit
still scrolling yeah so we started way
up here and we have all this scroll so
saved 829 new dependencies it's just
amazing yeah long scroll okay
we did get some warnings usually these
aren't really a big deal but you know if
you what if you're worried about them
you could always read them and then you
know correct that so in this case these
ones all are just saying that we have
something in dependencies we have
something in dev dependencies already
and we were also trying to add it in our
regular dependencies so not shouldn't
really big be a problem for us and if it
is we can switch it up later on
all right so we'll do a git status just
to make sure what's changed and this is
perfect this is what we expected to be
changed this package.json and our yard
and lock so let's test it out now before
we commit anything so I'm gonna go here
I think it'd probably be a good idea to
restart this server since we made so
many changes so we're just gonna exit
out so I hit ctrl C to stop that server
and then I just went with another yarn
dev and let's see we got a look we did
gets we have a warning here okay so we
have some weird stuff going on well it
looks like it's still loaded so let's
see what what we've got here
for these warnings so each out in an
array or iterator suge unique key
problem okay so evidently somewhere
we've forgotten to put a key fob and
Reformation okay so it has given us some
file names and line numbers where you
can check some of these things out so
maybe we can go through some of these
and fix them
you know what I have this air is it's
saying there's no entry and another
window I had I had a different project
open and I was also running that on
local I was 3,000 and it's still open so
I'm going to close that right now so we
get rid of all that mess all right
okay so let's check this out see what we
have going on let me let me do a hard
refresh so this video shows up - hmm it
should have shown up
I'm also gonna bring up dev tools to see
if we're getting any errors in the
console okay we have that key proc
warning again the same the prop type
warning okay
all right so we do have a few things
that we need to work through so that's
good if we had nothing to that went
wrong then it would have been a really
short stream okay I am gonna
double-check the live chat quickly just
to see if I've done anything wrong so
far or if you won't notice something in
any of the output that I didn't catch
oh here's a nice comment this is
interesting so John Hanson says I run
the NPM outdated it almost every time I
do an editing session fingers crossed
every time so I you know what I'm gonna
have to keep that in mind because it's
much easier to do very small incremental
updates than to do like I've done here
and wait months before we update
something so I think that that's a good
a good practice I'm gonna have to really
try to train myself to make a habit of
frequently updating especially when
we're in the process of building
something because at that time it's I
mean that's really the time to change
things and work out any bugs so I
actually really liked that idea and we
did have a question about whether or not
this was an actual website it is an
actual website you can find a link to it
in the description
it's kadek etics comm is the live
version so we're working on this locally
and then you all have the link to be
able to see this as well using Angra
right
okay so it looks like the only thing I'm
seeing in relation to what we've just
done is Hardison saying that he's not
getting an error in dev tools when he's
running this through through end rot so
that's that's interesting let me let me
try to empty the cache as well it should
already be anything since I have dev
tools open but we'll see I am a little
bit worried about why this video is not
loading anymore let's let's go through
some of these errors and fix these first
and if that video is still not loading
then we'll dig into it I don't know why
this would be messing up the video but
you never know it might fix it so we'll
just try it
Sanjay asks what is and rock and rock is
this little command-line tool that I
have here it's let me make it bigger as
you can see it so I get the name of the
person who made this is just slipping my
mind but his Twitter handle is izzat
inconceivable
he very generously has kind of donated
unlimited use of this to free code camp
for these streams but there's a free
version that has more limited use and
basically what you can do is run
something locally on your machine and
then turn on this little command-line
tool and it will give you a URL that you
can share with other people and they can
check out what you're doing locally in
real time from anywhere as long as they
have an internet connection so for these
streams it's very very helpful
hey harsh it's getting the errors now so
normally not happy to see errors but in
this case I'm glad that someone else is
seeing the errors as well alright and
har should also is seeing the video
that's interesting all right I'm not
gonna worry about the video now we'll
get to it at some point okay so let's
let's take these errors one by one so
oops I got a better description over
here oh no I didn't I didn't see this
we're actually getting the good
description here so that index dot
Chasse and she's 73 let's see if that's
if that's legit number so let's go in
here to that static yep just you know
what
it's just where our index chance is oh
it's in our pages folder that's where it
is it's trying to switch back and forth
between different like reacts routing
systems you kind of like forget where
things are that's what happened in this
case I forgot that we have everything in
pages when we're using next okay
let's double-check that number where do
we get 73 so let's check out 73
hmm
all right so if we add in a keeper up
here that should fix it so let's go with
key and let's give it the key prop let's
go
I wonder what I'm bringing in one if
we're going to the post ID
let's try post ID if I am pulling that
data this will work and it'll give it a
unique key so let's try it out
yeah it worked okay so I am bringing in
well I see some some of you in the live
chat we're saying I could just use the
index you you can you can definitely use
the index I to use the post ID as the
key because it's assuming that you're
getting the data from one WordPress
installation you're never going to have
the same key so that we'll make sure we
get a unique identifier there and in
cases where I don't have an ID I've used
like a random number before so I think
it's like UUID is the package and that
will also give you a kind of a nice
random number and this is just to make
sure that we don't accidentally have the
same values for key so basically
everything you want to have a different
key value all right let's check this one
out seventy nav so we're gonna look in
the nav component on line 73 so let's
check that out
where's our nav components components
there we go and nav alright 73 one nice
thing about next and I'm sure other
frameworks have things like this but one
nice thing about next is the error
messages are pretty descriptive and
helpful so it's usually not too bad
trying to debug things all right so we
have this link here and we have a hmm
okay so evidently on link title is not
valid to use
maybe this is something that's changed
in the newer version of next so this
this link is something that comes with
next and it has to do with the
prefetching so maybe title is not
available anymore I could just get rid
of the title and that would be okay but
instead I'd actually like to see if
there's an alternative here so let's
check out the documentation for next
it's been quite a while since I've
looked up this link tag stuff so there
we go let's see so here it is in prefix
you drop out the link
hmm so here's our link but
if we need we need more info so let's
see if there's more in depth ducks
that's that are linked to let's check
out learn next yes calm I haven't been
here for a while either I don't want
that I really don't want to do the
tutorial I just want to see the content
okay hard saying move the title to a tag
be a tag all right let's check that out
okay cool that makes sense and let's see
while we're on this screen this is
actually very helpful so learn next J s
comm will give you kind of a nice you
know guide to get you started if you've
never used next before John Hanson asked
if next was like react router next has
routing built into it so it has some
elements that do behave like react
router all right so I'm going to close
that out and I'll close this out there's
also a ton of great information just
right here in the git repo for next ok
so let me refresh ok it looks like we're
using that same that title in another
place so let's fix that now since we've
just done that we're sticking I have
line 15 so let's check out sticky nav
line 15 oh okay and it looks like we are
using this quite a bit so I'm guessing
that this used to be valid at one time
with next and then now it's not because
obviously we would have seen all these
errors before or at least you know the
warnings
so I'm just going to move all these down
here into these a tags so if you're not
familiar at all with what next does one
of the cool things that it can do is
prefetch pages so it can grab the HTML
four pages before the user is even
navigated to those pages and so that's
why we've wrapped our a tags in our link
tags so you don't have to prefetch with
the link tag if you just put the link
tag without this prefetch attribute then
it'll still do client-side routing for
you right so that means it's just going
to work out what's going to be on the
next page right there in the client
there's no page refresh that happens
right it doesn't have to hit the server
again but the prefetch is nice and it
results in much faster load times so
once the user gets that initial load
over with you know every click that they
go to where they're you know we had that
link prefetch tag is going to be nearly
instantaneous and we were first testing
this site after we launched it the
analytics the Google Analytics were
showing a load time of 0 seconds for all
the interior pages so that was I was
pretty excited about that I've never
seen zero cents for load son
okay okay harsh it did say that that
change came in next three because
they're not passing the tags to the a
tag so they're not passing the props to
the a tag so evidently before anything
else that you would put on this link tag
that wasn't immediately used by the link
tag like this prefetch or the href we
just automatically get passed down to
the a tag inside so I guess that's not
happening anymore so that's why it's
registering as an invalid tag so good to
know thanks hard [ __ ]
oh let's see what do we have here
okay so wow we're using this title I I
think we're gonna be chasing around
these these title attributes quite a
while so let's kind of this text reveal
image card and where was this at 73 wait
a second
21 okay all right so let's grab that and
put it down here
and save
okay great
okay hey I think we got rid of all those
linked attribute errors whoops click the
wrong thing there console all right
great now we can move on to another air
so we have a warning
I shouldn't say errors most of these are
just warnings if not all of them so I
mean obviously the site still working
did not expect server HTML to contain a
div in div okay
let's see if it's telling us what it's
telling us here
actually I'm gonna stop this and restart
it I just want to see the message again
that it gives me in the console to see
if there's any difference in what we're
seeing in our dev tools console versus
our terminal okay there's slight slight
difference
okay so check out team Jas
and where was it saying
hmm
I'm not really sure what the air is here
so I'm looking at this one now check the
top level render call usually do we're
looking at team jazz all right so my
timer just went off here so we'll think
about this one for a few minutes while
we do to some questions so let me take a
short 5-minute break and I'm gonna
scroll all the way up to the top of the
live chat and I go through and try to
get through as many questions as I can
okay a hardship mentioned early in the
stream that this was the react jQuery
mix project yeah yeah I I should
probably mention that in case some of
you are checking out the repo now or the
code this was an odd setup where we
blended jQuery with react so I'd
actually love to switch it over so we're
not using any jQuery at some point I
think I made an issue for that but
that's going to be a really big project
it's not entirely necessary right now
cuz everything's working but if we ever
get some time that might be a nice
project to do
let's see
blake is asking if anyone has written
batch scripts i don't really have that
much experience with with writing bash
script so i can't help you out too much
with that
okay Josh Modi'in was asking about a
project that he's creating but then he
had to go so sorry about that
if you can if you watch this later on
and you know maybe you still have some
questions join us for another live
stream or comment on this video you know
send me a message on Twitter or
something I'd be I'd be happy to talk to
you about your project
Phillips's could anyone recommend some
package or way to play notification
sounds in react app hmm I I don't know
that I've ever heard of a package I've
never really needed that so I've never
looked at it looked for it so I don't
know of any package is anybody else know
of anything like that could help out
Phillip a package that I would play
notification sounds and a react app
okay Philip asked does anyone know how
to do search engine optimization with
react without server-side rendering for
example Facebook sharing is still
showing react app as a title not sure
what to do mm sorry for the on again I
need some coffee or something
uh-huh okay so to do it without
server-side rendering yet I - honestly I
think the best way is with the
server-side rendering if you can't do
that kind of the older way to do things
would to be used something like phantom
Jes I think it's called
which basically like will serve two
crawlers like search engine crawlers or
things like that a version of your site
that is already been pre-rendered and
just kind of like stored so at least
that's my understanding of what those
things do it I've never really used them
but I have looked into using them before
and I decided that the server-side
rendering would be the better way to go
all right my time is almost up let's see
if I can get one more call it
questioning looks asking about is it
valid to put eight reps on the a tags
inside the link tags saying JSX the its
a11y but I really want to pronounce that
as a lie can I do that is that a thing
anyway it has to do with accessibility
for like screen readers and things so
anyway what I'm gonna start calling Ally
wants href on the a tags I I don't
really know
I'd say just try it out and see if it
works because it may be that it would
work all right like that but I'm
guessing that there are other people
that have thought about that and run
into that issue as well so if you try
and it doesn't work
I'm guessing this probably an issue for
that you know or somebody's brought it
up at some point
okay Hart should also mentioned using
puppeteer to serve up versions of your
site to to crawlers so that they see you
know what they should be saying yeah so
I've never used puppets here so I can't
personally say anything about it but you
might want to check that out as well
oh okay so evil has some advice for us
on that that last air that we got so
let's go back to the code now and let's
check that out
so one more Pomodoro session probably
just do one more and then probably wrap
things up around there we'll see we'll
see in any case at the end of the stream
we'll definitely you know get to all the
questions that you have in the live chat
all right so let's go back to okay so
Evo saying you know don't you need
parentheses in that map okay yeah let's
let's add some parentheses here and see
see what that does
you know the one here right
yeah should need to because we got one
too right yeah okay it was giving me a
red squiggly line at first I didn't
understand why all right let's try this
out now
so we've saved it let's do a refresh
here see what we get
[Music]
actually this this wasn't giving us what
we want to eat we got that air here so
let me restart the server and see what
air we get see if we get the same thing
I'm gonna check the live chat see if
there's any other discussion about this
all right that's okay we're still
getting that still at the same line all
right interesting
Harshit I see also said try navigating
right to the team page because there's
still more errors there so let's check
that out so we need a key prop there as
well
Wow was I thinking with these key props
this is like something that I rarely
forget now but you know was less
experienced when we are doing this site
like six months ago it's just kind of
amazing to look back and think how did I
forget key props on everything all right
so let's check it out
let's put a key in here and this can be
just like we did before let's do a post
ID okay Evo said it probably it does not
need parenthesis all right
well let's take him up then not a big
deal
alright but we didn't need to put a key
in there so that's good let's check back
whoa
okay so did not match server the client
didn't match the server that's
interesting let me let me show this
refresh again well that's odd I wonder
mmm
that's odd
hearted saying check out get initial
props
okay I notice how I should comment
Harsha's comment about puppeteer is
saying that I actually have used puppets
here because we were using it for NN
testing you know that now that you say
that I do I remember puppeteer was in
there so I'm using it kind of indirectly
I don't handle it it just runs when we
do our test so alright so let's see I
mean we should be getting
I'm wondering if this may be just
something weird is going on locally whoa
interesting yeah when I go to it like
this obviously we don't get it but when
we refresh and see if we get it again
yep we do okay so on refresh we get that
I said you're saying and also remember
for this project we have a test server
on digital ocean so we can run this in
production mode and see if we're still
getting this kind of thing happening so
we're gonna have another whole nother
level of tests going on all right
okay well that seems to be the only
thing that we have happening now on the
team page
okay coach
that's ko Jae I'm just gonna say coach
for now correct me if that's the wrong
pronunciation
it says the div and a bear seems to be
because you're somehow initially
rendering a different tree on the client
versus a server yeah I just I don't I'm
not seeing right now how or why it's
rendering differently let's take a look
again at this page and see what we're
doing in the team closer
interesting
this
okay okay
all right so they're at this page works
perfectly fine when you navigate to it
through the client-side routing but when
you navigate through you know when it's
the first load through the server-side
routing it doesn't work there's just a
bunch of data that's missing so harsh is
saying restart the server maybe it's the
cache ok yeah let's try that all right
so let's restart the server see what we
get
mmm okay still getting this error
okay still that let's try to refresh
yeah still still getting that error
okay John sang how I should sing show up
in the terminal John sang maybe there's
some inline styles that are causing that
error all right so it looks like this is
all we're getting on that latest restart
okay so we are getting we do checkout
hedge as you know what let me check this
out really quickly because this seems
like something that's a really easy fix
so let's just do it while we see it
there and then we'll go back to this
team page
there's five
there we go
all right so let's check out initially I
thought we were having some issue with
our jQuery but if that was the case we
wouldn't be able to open these modal's
so I don't think that's the problem the
problem this is odd let's see we're
getting here yes
no we're like we're getting some data
but not other data right so we get all
this but not this and we should be able
to get that let's see what we're doing
where are we getting that data
because concert rendered
and this is our
all right you know that's the top
section so we're not worried about that
but that is coming in properly right yes
it is okay so let's go down here to our
cards I just can't remember exactly how
I did this before it's too long ago I'm
trying to see where where exactly that
data is getting put in for the modal
there you go contents for a team card
here and then the bottom modal's
I'm gonna see where we have our modal's
all right let's check out the team card
component then
this rose content
all right let's check out our static
JavaScript file I think I remember what
was happening
oh man I was using fair - this is a
little bit painful to watch - look at
this code
hmm
all right while we're in here I'm gonna
remove these console logs because we
don't need those
get out of here console logs all right
let me check the live chat harsh is
saying isomorphic fetch seems like an
error with the fetch okay let's see what
I'm using here yeah I am bringing in
isomorphic fetch
all right let me check got a question
here about this code again so we're I'm
saying there this card equals this
saying does that make sense it might not
make sense it's been a while since I
wrote this Levite when are you using
this card this I don't know it's
possible that it was necessary to make
this variable at some point and then I
changed the code and it wasn't and I
never switched it back it's possible I
just didn't know what I was doing and I
did that unnecessarily so I'm not gonna
try to refactor this right now because
we're gonna completely get rid of all
this jQuery at some point so I'm not
gonna worry about anything in here right
now
only if it's like I absolutely have to
fix something because it doesn't work
anymore
all right let's see coach is saying what
is good
st. component did mount is not available
and rendering on the server you're
setting up some data there which appears
to be in conflict the conflict between
the client the server okay page the team
colored sections you know there
shouldn't there's nothing going on with
data in here this just and it's these
and you can see here this is just
initializing like the modal's in
material materialized CSS so there
shouldn't be any change of the data all
it should all it should be doing is just
allowing us the modal to open and then
allowing us to open and close these
sections
okay let me check my time
whoo seven minutes all right
let's look at this again
yeah it does seem it does seem like
we're not getting that call made on the
server side like like you all were
saying because here when we see the
server does nothing no data but then for
the client we have all this I mean this
is all the stuff this is only this stuff
that's supposed to go see yeah yeah this
is only the data that's supposed to go
inside the modal let's look back at
where we're putting that component in
the in the modal or where we're putting
that data into the modal I don't think
we have a separate modal component right
all right so let's see where this is it
should be grabbing this data team member
yeah we're grabbing all the data from
the team members this is this is where
we have our API calls to the WordPress
API
all right so that's the top section we
don't need to worry about that
that would do this I definitely do this
differently if I were making it now but
it works
okay so we are putting the content we're
passing that to team card all right let
me check team card again I don't think
we need that anymore we don't need that
fixed all that let me fix that okay all
right so let's see what we're doing with
content
okay so we have a div with a class of
content we've setting it to display:none
I think we can take this out let's try
taking this out
let me try to restate
same thing
actually let me check now
remember this was working if we went to
it with the client-side so let me make
sure I didn't mess it that up as well
now it's still there see so that section
that we had before was completely
unnecessary so that was probably left
over from initially before we turned
this into react the way we're doing the
modal's was unclick it grabbed the data
from that particular div and then
because you're clicking on this
container dev so we're gonna grab the
data within it and use that to populate
the modal and then once we went to react
we switched it up and we actually have a
modal for each instance of the team card
component and then we put the data
directly in that so we didn't really
have a need of that anymore
so we'll just get rid of it that was
completely unnecessary so now let's move
on and see what's going on with this
content
Stephen says is it getting hung up on
the first full yeah yeah it only doesn't
work if if it's the first load is right
to the team's page
John Henson says should prop Tice be
added to all components is it used in
the production build or is it just for
development troubleshooting now we
probably don't need prop types for all
our components you could use prop types
prop types are nice it lets people know
you know who are going to be using this
like exactly the content that you should
have I haven't used them a lot but it
might not be a bad practice to do
nice this is interesting okay so what
let's look at what we are getting in the
modal so I believe we're getting this
this h4 which is the name and we're
getting this title let's double check
that whoops let me let me refresh and
we'll double check
yeah so we're getting the name we're
getting the title let's see
I I guess this is included as part of
the title
wait a second team cart or okay here we
go team cart org here and then usually
said oh no that was content hard [ __ ] in
this case we're we're not going with
content renders so we've already passed
this down as content rendered here so as
a prop on team card we don't need to put
rendered we go back here
I guess we don't really need that this
is to being a P tag since we're getting
P tags so I'm just gonna I don't think
this is the problem but I am going to
change this to div hopefully I don't
have something going on with the styles
for that hey hey it works
what all right I'm gonna just verify
again that it works interesting
all right cool that works and it worked
before I change this to a day of so I
don't think that really matters but what
did we do I don't even remember what I
changed I don't think I changed anything
except I remove that data from here
right we remove that data from up here
we restarted the server it didn't work
and now we have this Google Analytics
getting messed up here alright so this
works now I guess that's okay when you
accidentally fix a bug this for this
page so
I'll page you when we're running this
okay
this is
all right so now there's something going
on here with the page you I I'm not that
worried about this as long as as long as
it shows up client-side at some point
and logs the page you I guess I'm fine
with that
I'm assuming that this got updated react
GA so maybe something changed with that
package so we may have to take a look at
this package and see if anything changed
if we're still using it properly all
right so my timer did run out so I'm
gonna go down to the live chat I'm gonna
catch up with any questions that you all
have and then we're going to wrap things
up and I'm gonna try to find some
caffeine
Sebastian says does this repo have
prettified you mean prettier
it says if it does try running it
without it
you think maybe something that in there
is causing the errors I'll try it if I
get really stuck and can't get through
the error so I'll take a look at the
syntax and see if that's the case
whoa all right so everybody were talking
about Ally a11y so like a 11y and
someone said they pronounce it Ally as
well who was that I can't find it now
oh look said that and then rook said the
amount of characters between the a and
the Y and the word accessibility is 11
that's really cool so I mean I assuming
that's where they got the name from
that's that is pretty awesome
John Ensign says I finally figured it
out submit form data with fetch to PHP
mailer gave up on Google reCAPTCHA as
it's so hard to implement happy with my
client side validation site is live but
not finished so I that's awesome John
great job on that yeah I definitely send
it send us a link whenever you're ready
for from people to see it I'd love to
check it out
okay I see the link you put in there now
John so I'll I'll check that out after
the stream I'm putting it in my browser
right now so I don't forget
all right Wow I got through the live
chat so not not a whole lot of questions
I did kind of go back and forth you
clean code and chat a little bit more I
normally do so that may explain it all
right so not a bad stream we got a lot
of time we worked through a lot of
errors for the most part things are
still working we didn't check out every
page so you know we may run into some
issues that are a lot more difficult but
I feel like this is going to be doable
and I'm glad that that we're upgrading
everything first then we're gonna go in
and add the new features you know change
the layout a bit which I can share all
that with you or if you want to preview
some of it check out the repo and read
the issues that I've put in recently but
it'll be nice to take advantage of you
know the newer versions of next and
react and some of that you know
performance improvement that we should
get alright so I guess that's it for
today thanks everyone for watching
thanks for all your help and your
comments and the live chat that that
helped me a lot to kind of get through
and figure out what was going on
tomorrow I should be back tomorrow
around the same time that will be my
last stream for a while so the entire
next week I will not be working the
Christmas break so I won't be back until
after the new year so I think I'm back
January 2nd so that'll we'll see what's
going on when I get back hopefully if I
have time then January 2nd will then be
when I come back for streaming so
probably a stream tomorrow and then not
again till January 2nd maybe I'll try to
get some like pre-recorded videos out on
my own YouTube channel you can find the
link in the description to this video
I I do have some content ready that I
just haven't recorded yet so we'll see
kind of defense I guess on how loud my
kids are and if they get to sleep early
so I can record but anyway I can't
promise anything
I mean if my kids get really good toys
or video games and I want to play them I
I might not have time to record a video
so you know how that guess all right so
yeah so if I don't see a John says I may
not see tomorrow Merry Christmas Happy
New Year see any of you tomorrow for the
stream yeah definitely Merry Christmas
Happy New Year and if you get in some
time off you know definitely and enjoy
your time off
try not to code too much hang out with
your family and friends you know just
relax and and I'll see y'all some of you
I'll see tomorrow and if I don't then
I'll see you next year
have a great day